pft on yahoo sports mike florio peter
king with you talking about the big
stories in the nfl sometimes the big
stories just drop out of the sky during
a post-game press conference after a
playoff game when a star quarterback
decides unsolicited
to raise a question about his own future
and make everyone say what in the world
is aaron rodgers talking about and it
sparked plenty of discussion about what
he wants where he will be what the
packers want which based upon how he
played this year peter king is more
aaron rodgers but what's your take on
this kind of sudden and abrupt but given
what we know about aaron rodgers by no
means accidental message he's sending
you know mike i find it interesting that
the guy who said
one week before sunday
and i'm paraphrasing that it's such a
privilege
to play quarterback for this team i love
this team
and then
one week later
and mike
not in any way
throwing all the blame on aaron rodgers
at all but a guy who goes incomplete
incomplete incomplete
on the biggest series of the year
and for some reason on the third pass
through
a ground ball to devonta adams
who was absolutely
in as tight a coverage as you can be in
by two tampa bay buccaneers it was a
meaningless stupid pass
and now all of a sud and when when he
had a pasture in front of him would he
have made it i've heard a lot of debate
about whether he would have made the
touch scored a touchdown or not my gut
feeling is
he would have
but i don't know that he would have but
i do know
that matt lafleur's decision would have
been a lot different on fourth and goal
from the two
than it was on fourth and goal from the
eight
when three plays in a row there's an
there are incompletions including a bad
one on the third one
so
i i understand aaron rodgers very very
frustrated
but here and and look he might come to
the team he might
and say i'm not playing here anymore
period i'm i'm done
uh and they might not have any choice
but i would like to see that happen
before we
start uh
putting him
under center for the san francisco 49ers
next year
i think that one of the things this is
about and it doesn't just have to be
about one thing but
he wants a new contract that's what i've
been told that's what i've heard i trust
my source on that and it makes sense
when you look at what he's making in
comparison to the other great
quarterbacks when you look at how he's
played in relation to the other
quarterbacks he currently makes the same
as jared goff which tells you
with nothing else
that that
is a situation that suggests aaron
rodgers isn't getting what he truly
deserves and what a new contract also
would give him peter is security the way
these contracts get structured you know
in the early years they're not going to
trade you they're not going to cut you
you're going to be around for two or
three more years i think he doesn't want
to have this jordan love thing hovering
over his shoulder and the best way to
turn it into more like jimmy garoppolo
and less like aaron rodgers as to brett
favre is to get a contract that makes it
clear the packers continue to be all in
with aaron rodgers that may be the
primary motivation for him thrusting his
future
unprompted into uncertainty
i don't i don't i i i don't think that's
a bad idea at all mike and and if that's
what this is about
that's fine but i think he does need to
understand that
if the packers did this right now
i think the contract would have to be
significantly backloaded
um and backloaded not with incentives
but with real money for a very simple
reason the cap this year probably next
year isn't going to be going up as it
has been normally maybe next year it
will but i doubt this year it's going to
go up at all it's probably going to go
down so
you know what you're saying what aaron
rodgers should say to the team
i want uh desean watson money right now
and you can structure it in some way i
just need to be sure i'm going to get
the money
yeah and get the years that's the key
know that you're going to be there this
year next year and the next year and if
anyone goes it's going to be jordan love
not aaron rodgers that's it for now he's
peter king i'm mike florio we'll see you
next time
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports